bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le front uni des
occidentaux face à la russie un front
anti poutine cimentée par joe biden pour
resserrer les rangs des alliés autour de
l'ukraine le président américain présent
aux trois sommets à bruxelles
aujourd'hui l'otan le g7 et l'union
européenne qui ont décidé de nouvelles
mesures revirement stratégique complet
livraison de nouvelles armes à l'ukraine
et projet de plafonnement des prix du
gaz on va revenir dans le détail sur
toutes ses décisions dans notre grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
on parlera aussi des conséquences de ce
conflit pour nos agriculteurs pris à la
gorge face à l'envolée des prix des
matières premières le risque de pénurie
de blé pourrait entraîner aussi des
famines en afrique et dans les pays du
maghreb emmanuel macron vient de
proposer à bruxelles un mécanisme de
solidarité humanitaire nous en parlerons
avec le ministre de l'agriculture julien
de normandie est avec nous ce soir enfin
ce sera la page présidentielle comme
chaque soir à 17 jours du premier tour
dans le scad l'oeil de blacko s'attarde
sur la non campagne d' emmanuel macron
vive la république ou vive la france
thomas legrand reviendra sur les choix
sémantique de jean luc mélenchon est
déréglée bon enfin benjamin rente grange
à regarder de très près la réaction des
réseaux sociaux sur ces entreprises
françaises qui décide de rester en
russie voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est
parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous trois sommets trois sommets
pour encercler pour resserrer l'étau sur
vladimir poutine et stopper cette guerre
en ukraine sans la faire regarder cette
image du g7 joe biden vous la
découvrirez entouré des dirigeants des
plus grandes économies mondiales comme
un parfum de monde libre soudés face au
maître du kremlin on va parler des
images et des premières décisions qui
nous parviennent ce soir avec vous
nicole bacharan bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes historienne politologue
spécialiste des états unis votre dernier
ouvrage co écrit avec dominique simonet
les grands jours qui ont changé
l'amérique c'était aux éditions perrin
bonsoir ronan le gleut merci d'être là
vous êtes sénateur des républicains des
français de l'étranger membre de la
commission de la défense on a besoin de
votre expertise sur ce qui s'est joué
aujourd'hui au sommet de l'otan bonsoir
maria eugenia sanaa merci d'être avec
nous maître de conférences en économie à
paris saclay spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et bonsoir patrick martin
geniez spécialiste des questions
internationales et européennes il ya un
sommet de l'union ce soir vous êtes
également enseignant à sciences po et
essayiste enfin je salut l'ami richard
verdi depuis bruxelles bonsoir richard
nous y sommes vous êtes au conseil
européen à bruxelles vous avez suivi
toute cette journée très riche en
annonces et on me signale vous allez
nous dire d'un mot que derrière vous les
petites lumières bleues qui clignote
c'est le convoi de joe biden c'est ça
effectivement sur le rond point schuman
qui se trouve juste derrière moi autour
duquel se trouvent les institutions
européennes est bien celle énorme convoi
de joe biden le président américain lui
il est entré dans ce bâtiment il y a un
peu près 30 minutes avec une heure de
retard par contre son convoi bloc
l'intégralité de ce rond-point le au
menu de joe biden avec les européens
c'est surtout les sanctions puisque
toute la partie militaire a été discuté
comme vous l'avez dit myriam lors du
sommet de l'otan ce matin à l'autre bout
de la capitale belge on va regarder
regarder dans le détail quelles sont
c'est premières décisions qui ont été
prises au niveau militaire mais
peut-être pour commencer avec vous riche
qu'est ce que vous retenez en tant que
journaliste en tant que ses observateurs
de ces questions à la fois européenne
internationales de défense également de
cette de cette journée
fondamentale ce qui me paraît clair
c'est premièrement que l'alliance donc
les alliés au sein de l'otan mais
également les économies les plus riches
au sein du g7 se prépare à une guerre
longue emmanuel macron l'a dit les
négociations ne déboucheront sans doute
pas tout de suite les discussions avec
des lanières poutine ne laisse pas
penser que le président russe est
aujourd'hui prêt à un cessez-le-feu et
c'est précisément parce qu'on se prépare
à une guerre longue qu'on va nous vaut
discuter sanctions ici au conseil
européen
l'élément l'autre élément qu'il faut
retenir c'est que pour l'instant l'otan
ne veux pas parler de lignes rouges
tous les intervenants à commencer par le
président biden ne veulent pas évoquer
nos yeux rouges en cas d'utilisation
d'armes chimiques on parle de riposte on
parle de de capacité de l'otan à
répondre à une éventuelle utilisation de
ces armes mais pas question de fixer
instruits qui éventuellement on ne
pourrait pas tenir parce qu'à ce
moment-là ça mettrait l'alliance dans
une situation extrêmement difficile
merci richard on revient vers vous très
vite on va voir ça maintenant en images
les principaux dirigeants des grandes
économies de ce monde réuni à bruxelles
où tous les regards étaient évidemment
braqués aujourd'hui sujet estimé
stéphane et des terres un mois jour pour
jour après le début de la guerre les
alliés affichent leur unité et le
président américain est sur la photo joe
biden a fait le déplacement jusqu'à
bruxelles pour une journée de marathon
diplomatique avec un objectif maintenir
la pression sur la russie premier rendez
vous ce matin le sommet extraordinaire
de l'otan juste avant dans une vidéo le
président ukrainien a demandé une
nouvelle fois des armes aux occident
pour sauver la population et nos villes
l'ukraine a besoin d'une assistance
militaire sans restriction de la même
manière que la russie utilise tout son
arsenal sans restriction contre nous la
russie détruites ou des maisons aux
églises en passant par les entrepôts
alimentaire les universités les ponts
les hôpitaux
un message en partie entendue par les
alliés qui annoncent de nouvelles
livraisons de matériel militaire et
d'outils de cybersécurité les etats unis
pourraient fournir des missiles
antinavires à l'ukraine l'otan renforce
aussi sa présence à l'est avec l'envoi
de quatre nouveaux bataillons en
bulgarie roumanie hongrie et slovaquie
quarante mille soldats sont déjà
positionnés dans la partie orientale de
l'europe volodymyr zen ce qu'il a dit ce
matin il craint désormais une
utilisation d'armes chimiques à grande
échelle une menace jugée crédible par
joe biden et par l'otan qui s'y
préparent
d'autres commandants militaires le
général voltaire à activer les éléments
de défense chimiques biologiques
radiologiques et nucléaires de l'otan et
les alliés déploie des défenses
chimiques biologiques et nucléaires
supplémentaires pour renforcer nos
groupements tactiques existants et
nouveaux seins nus par kings l'attaquent
russe a fait resurgir l'utilité de
l'otan qui poursuit son soutien aux
ukrainiens en tentant d'éviter
l'escaladé la ligne reste la même pour
l'ensemble des alliés continuer à
fournir des armes défensives et létal le
faire dans un cadre
d'efficacité
mais avec une ligne rouge vous savez qui
continue de ne pas être comme
belligérants cet après-midi les pays du
g7 se sont aussi dits prêts à prendre de
nouvelles sanctions si nécessaire contre
moscou et les européens se retrouvent ce
soir pour un sommet à 27
on va réinitialiser l'otan voilà ce que
disait le secrétaire général de la
grande alliance atlantique en ouverture
du sommet est ce que c'est chose faite
ce soir dans le bleu on a l'impression
que voilà poutine voulait l'affaiblir il
revient en force le changement est
extrêmement profond brack obama avait
théorisé le pivot asiatique c'est à dire
la confrontation pour le leadership
mondial entre
la chine et les états unis et est donc
leur déploiement d'un certain nombre de
forces militaires américaines
stationnées sur le continent européen
vers le changement d'océan de l'océan
atlantique vers l'océan pacifique
ce qui est en train de s'opérer depuis
le début de l'année c'est autre chose en
réalité on passe de 80 mille militaires
américains présents sur le sol européen
à 100 milles ce qui n'a pas que l'on n'a
pas vu sur le continent européen depuis
15 ans donc il ya véritablement une
montée en puissance de la présence
militaire américaine sur le sol européen
qui va totalement à l'encontre de ce
pivot asiatiques qui néanmoins avait
commencé à démarrer à partir du moment
de la prise de conscience de l'annexion
de la crimée par la russie et dans les
décisions extrêmement fortes qui ont été
annoncés aujourd'hui il ya évidemment la
création de quatre groupements tactiques
ouais les fameux 4 bataillons dans les
pays est roumanie slovaquie hongrie
bulgarie voilà il existait déjà quatre
groupements tactiques en pologne dans un
pareil dans les états baltes avant pour
les trois états baltes et là on a une
montée en puissance et notamment la
france avec le déploiement de 550 hommes
sur la roumanie ce qui n'était pas le
cas nous n'avions pas de présence
militaire de soldats français sur le sol
roumain donc on voit bien que il ya un
déploiement sur le flanc est de de
l'otan et est ce ce déploiement ces
quatre nouveaux groupements tactiques
sont une nécessité une réassurance pour
ces états et d'ailleurs ils le
demandaient depuis longtemps bien sûr
longtemps que la lenteur qui sont très
inquiet mais à la question c'est est-ce
que ça va suffire est ce que ça n'arrive
pas trop tard au fond l'otan montre les
muscles
on va voir s'il ya des patrouilles ou
pas s'il ya une véritable volonté
politique aussi d'envoyer des messages
de fermeté à vladimir poutine là on ne
parle pas de l'aide directe aux
ukrainiens on parle de notre sécurité
parce que les polonais et tous les pays
de l'est sont extrêmement inquiets
est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas un peu trop
tard aussi qu'au contraire ce soir il
faut se féliciter de ce retour dans le
jeu géopolitique de l'otan je ne sais
pas s'il faut se féliciter en tout cas
c'était indispensable c'était le minimum
qu'on puisse faire un
qu'on parle de réinitialiser l'otan j'ai
des doutes sur le terme en tout cas
c'est le retour des troupes américaines
en europe c'est le terme des secrétaires
et la réinitialisation ça prendra bien
plus de temps 1 c'est une urgence c'est
l'urgence et le retour des troupes
américaines parce que l'europe est
menacé dans sa survie il faut le dire
c'est à dire que vladimir poutine a
menacé l'europe dans son intégrité et ce
qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le fait
d'envoyer ses troupes s'est rassurée
notamment des polonais tous les pays de
l'est de l'europe en disant l'otan est
là et nous n'accepterons pas quelques
arrêts sont que ce soit sur le
territoire d'un pays de l'otan mais vous
avez bien vu que on parle d'une ligne
rouge c'est un peu flou qu'est-ce que
cela signifie
joe biden vient de dire qu en cas
d'utilisation d'armes biologiques ou
chimiques il y aurait une réponse mais
on sait très bien que avant même qu'il
n'arrive la maison blanche avait
clairement dit qu'il n'y aura pas
d'intervention de toute façon en ukraine
donc effectivement c'est rassurer les
pays européens de façon à ce que les
etats-unis soient là pour les protéger
ce qui ne va pas empêcher l'europe de
devoir réfléchir à une meilleure
autonomie stratégique dans les années
qui viennent donc l'europe se protège
très clairement nicole bacharan mais
pour les ukrainiens c'est vrai que on a
encore entendu aujourd'hui volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien demander
une aide militaire sans restriction et
ce soir personne pas même joe biden est
vraiment capable de dire voilà la ligne
rouge voilà les germes chimiques les
armes bactériologiques qui sont très
clairement posé sur la table par poutine
ont ripostera en compter sur nous c'est
dramatique j'ai envie de dire que c'est
dramatique c'est vrai vous l'avez tous
les deux très bien dit le renforcement
de la présence de l'otan aux frontières
s de l'otan c'est quelque chose de très
utiles d'indispensable mais on peut pas
dire que l'otan avec malgré tout en
premier responsable joe biden sache
jouer le jeu de la dissuasion le jeu de
la n'y aura jamais de dire qu'il
interviendrait jamais avant même
l'entrée en guerre à vous rappeler très
justement que à quoi bon dire jamais
jamais l'otan mirent à en ukraine on
pouvait dire toutes les cartes sont sur
la table et avait aucune raison de
rassurer
la dmr poutine de même le terme de
lignes rouges pas besoin de vous refaire
l'histoire est un terme malheureux
puisque une fois que cette ligne a été
dessinée elle a été ensuite ignoré par
barack obama mais c'est vrai que sur le
degré de tolérance de l'otan ça reste
flou est ce que par exemple si un
missile une roquette ou un char entrent
sur le territoire polonais ou baltes
que va-t-il se passer est ce que
localement normalement c'est l'achat des
alliances etc on y va où est ce qu'ils
vont dire homme il faut qu'on discute
vous avez un doute j'ai eu un doute ce
temps que vladimir poutine jouera avec
cette limite par exemple est-ce que
l'otan et ça serait pas totalement
stupide mais est ce que va discuter est
ce que c'est un accident est-ce qu'elle
ait pas de mauvaises intentions est ce
que c'est vraiment une attaque et c'est
la même chose tragiquement donc vous
voyez encore une très grande faiblesse
de l'avion je pense que le langage mais
ça assez ferme pour décourager vladimir
poutine dante d'incursions à la limite
de l'otan ou des usages d'armes de
destruction massive avec ça malgré la
présence aujourd'hui en europe à
bruxelles oui de joe biden qui va aller
en pologne après on s'est mariés oui
parce qu on a l'habitude de citer cet
article 5 des nations 2 de la charte de
l'eau cela la fameuse clause
d'assistance mutuelle le problème c'est
que il faut aussi décider effectivement
vous l'avez dit est ce que les
conditions d'une intervention soreli il
y a même pas quinze jours un drone qui
est partie d'ukraine est allé jusqu à
zagreb et donc à exposer est à zagreb
n'y a pas eu de blessé mais plusieurs
véhicules cotés détruits et donc là on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé il y avait quand
même un drone il aurait pu décharger
d'une arme donc effectivement je pense
que même si par hasard
miss il devait peut-être par accident
arrivé en pologne je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion je ne suis pas certain que le
temps ba pourrait décider d'une ovadia
d'une guerre mondiale parce qu'un seul
missile ce serait ton retrait tombé sur
le célèbre je vais vous demander si vous
êtes d'accord avec ça mais je vais aller
voir tout de suite richard wehrli qui a
suivi cette cette journée et ce sommet
de l'otan quelles sont les réactions ce
soir est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
la tonalité de ce plateau peut mieux
faire quand même
oui je ne suis pas sûr c'est à dire
qu'il faut bien comprendre que l'otan
comme l'union européenne ils ont le même
objectif c'est de forcer vladimir
poutine a négocié en groupe personne ne
pense qu'on peut battre sur le terrain
l'armée russe donc il y à une posture
qui consiste à vraiment essayé
d'étouffer au maximum la russie d'abord
par les sanctions emmanuel macron a dit
qu' aujourd'hui l'économique russe était
déjà en état de banqueroute
et de ce point de vue on peut comprendre
la logique de l'otan c'est qu'on ne fixe
pas de lignes rouges parce que quelque
part vladimir poutine pourrait être
tenté de les tester et ça mettrait
l'alliance en grande difficulté mais
quand vous entendez le secrétaire
général de l'otan qui dit que toutes les
alertes chimiques ont été activés on
peut imaginer en tout cas il faut
l'espérer que les moyens de riposte sont
déjà en place prenant le bleu c'est vrai
que ce soir aussi l'otan décident de se
prémunir contre des attaques chimiques à
la fois du côté des dates le temps et de
l'europe mais aussi d'envoyer des armes
et ça c'est très important contre ces
armes chimiques si elles étaient
utilisées aux ukrainiens côté livraisons
d'armes est ce qu'on est à la hauteur de
l'urgence
clairement une montée en puissance
plusieurs états font part de ce qu'ils
livrent notamment de missiles antichars
la france a décidé ne pas communiquer
sur les chiffres je pense que la france
a raison de ne pas communiquer ce type
d'information enfin il ya des choses qui
ont été révélés par la presse notamment
des missiles anti aériens milan en tout
cas ce qui est important effectivement
et ça a été décidé aujourd'hui c'est de
livrer à la fois du matériel de
détection des nerfs baisser les armes
donc
radiologique biologique chimique
et de protection donc ça c'est une bonne
décision mais pour revenir sur la notion
de lignes rouges moi je considère que
l'otan est la ligne rouge et que
l'article 5 même si ce n'est pas une
automaticité il n'y a pas automaticité
de l'emploi de la force avec tels que
l'article 5 et rédigé néanmoins je
considère que la ligne rouge elle est là
et on peut qu'on pourra compter sur
l'otan si cette ligne rouge et vos
interlocuteurs vous travaillez sur ces
sujets sont sur la même ligne parce
qu'il ya le juridique il ya un article
de traiter et puis ensuite son
application dans la réalité la réalité
on la voit c'est un nouveau déploiement
depuis en particulier depuis janvier de
20 mille militaires supplémentaires
américains sur le sol européen avec une
concentration sur le flanc est un
déploiement de militaires
supplémentaires et comme on l'a déjà dit
de la france sur le flanc est et par
conséquent c'est la présence de
notamment d'aider des boys américains
dans les pays est une dimension
extrêmement importante parce que l'armée
américaine est fondamentale elle est la
première armée de l'otan la france à la
première armée d'europe très clairement
mais les états unis ont la première
armée de l'otan un million quatre cent
mille soldats 700 milliards de budget
annuel rien que sur la présence
européenne en europe de l'armée
américaine on est sur 36 milliards de
dollars le budget de la france et 40
c'est à dire que des états unis
dépensent presque l'équivalent de la
totalité de notre budget militaire
français sur le sol européen il faut
avoir les ordres de grandeur pour se
rend compte combien la première armée de
l'otan est infiniment plus puissante que
les armées qui composent l'otan nicole
bacharan peut-être quand même vous qui
êtes spécialisé états unis
hayden présence a du sens quand même ça
a du sens et c'est fort effectivement ce
déploiement militaire renforcée que vous
vous rappelez c'est important bien sûr
mais néanmoins on n'est pas du tout à
l'abri à la fois d'un accident ou d'une
incursion malheureuse ou même
franchement d'une incompréhension
puisqu'on a appris aujourd'hui que les
ministres de la défense et le patron du
pentagone enfin le ministre de la
défense et le président de l'état major
américaine arrivée n'était jamais pris
au téléphone par leurs homologues russes
c'est totalement inhabituel même en
pleine guerre froide
ce canal était maintenu justement au cas
où il y aurait une incompréhension des
mouvements mal interprété et finalement
quand ça ne se pensait que ça ne parlent
pas ils nous aiment le pas en ce moment
tout car est parce qu on sait aussi que
les américains à mettre à disposition
tous leurs enseignements mais on est
plus craignant qu'il ya aussi une sorte
de guerre a dit story se fait à un
niveau inférieur mais sur le terrain
vous avez des jeunes officiers des
pilotes les sous mariniers qui peuvent
parfaitement dérapé et entraîner voilà
des conséquences dramatiques je voulais
vous montrer une image et puis on va
passer à la question énergétique avec
vous sur le terrain maintenant tous les
observateurs les meilleurs spécialistes
militaires 10 d'après justement les
renseignements américains les images
satellites que l'armée russe est en
train de s'enliser que la machine
offensive semble en tous les cas bloquée
malgré le carnage des villes bombardées
comme mario paul il ya un navire russe
fleuron d'ailleurs de l'armée russe qui
a été vu en pleine incendie on le voit à
l'écran en feu près de marioupol on est
on est à berne dix ans que sur la mer
d'azov et c'est l'ukraine qui communique
un ces images qui il affirme l'avoir
détruit est-ce que voilà c'est une une
forme de signes de symboles que
l'ukraine résiste et beaucoup plus qu'on
ne l'avait imaginé il s'agit ici d'un
navire de débarquement de deux classes
alligator qui a une capacité de pour
contenir 50 chars donc effectivement
vous voyez il s'agit véritablement d'une
opération importante
très clairement l'objectif de du
président de la fédération de russie
était une opération extrêmement rapide
il avait plutôt envisager de réussir
dans un temps extrêmement court ce qui
est ce qui est à ce qui arrive n'est
absolument pas ce qui était prévu dans
une carte ailleurs de l'offensive russe
en ukraine pendant que vous nous
expliquer les choses aller ce qui est
très fort c'est que là on est en zone
russophone bergantz c'est en ozone
russophones et et à marioupol aussi
c'est à dire que le niveau de résistance
des ukrainiens russophone surprend
routine qui s'attendait à être
accueillis en libérateurs et il se
produit exactement l'inversé c'est à
dire que le fait le tiers d'ukrainiens
russophone sont extrêmement attachés à
la nation ukrainienne et ça ce n'était
absolument pas dans le logiciel du
kremlin alors on va passer à l'autre
grand dossier qui permettrait peut-être
d'asphyxié l'effort de guerre de poutine
les financements de cette guerre c'est
la question énergétique
je vais me tourner vers vous richard
vernis pour essayer d'y voir un peu plus
clair on a entendu emmanuel macron
parler de diversification énergétique en
allant chercher du gaz ailleurs du
pétrole ailleurs on a entendu aussi les
canadiens qui sont évidemment présents
dans le cadre de cet été dans le cadre
de l'otan dire qu'ils allaient eux aussi
peut-être fournir à l'europe du gaz et
du pétrole qu'est ce qu'on sait ce soir
est ce que l'embargo sur le gaz et de
pétrole russe est impossible il ne sera
pas décidée c'est sur les allemands
mettre un mettre un veto là-dessus
toujours alors que l'embargo sur les
hydrocarbures au sens un choix décidé
aujourd'hui ou demain matin puisque le
sommet européen va se poursuivre à
bruxelles ça paraît extrêmement
improbable par contre ce qui est très
clair c'est que joe biden va venir avec
des promesses il va être interrogé par
ses partenaires européens sur le thème
quelle quantité de gaz petit fournir
quelle infrastructure faut-il pour que
le gaz liquéfié en provenance
des états unis arrivent en abondance
suffisantes pour remplacer le gaz russe
donc faut c'est une discussion non
seulement énergétique mais économique à
long terme parce que ce genre
d'investissement savent allier d'une
certaine manière irrémédiablement
l'europe sur le plan énergétique aux
états unis notamment c'est donc une
véritable révolution qui est en train de
se passer et qui va commencer
aujourd'hui ici pas seulement sur le
plan énergétique mais aussi pour
l'avenir économique parce que qui dit
énergie dit fonctionnement des économies
européennes merci richard maria eugenia
sanaa vous êtes d'accord avec ce mot de
révolution dans nos approvisionnements
énergétiques même si tout ne se décidera
pas tout de suite et moi je pense que
pour rebondir d'ailleurs sur la
discussion d'avant
des quelque sorte en parlant de la ligne
rouge et
il me semble que on n'est pas conscient
jusqu'à quel point on est interdépendant
et des laroussi d'un pas vue énergétique
donc on n'est pas conscient de la force
qu'on peut avoir et donc si on mettait
un embargo jusqu'à quel point ça
pourrait être compliqué pour la route
alors ça c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
savoir c'est à dire que on sait que on a
40% de gaz qui vient de russie si on
coupe le gazoduc north stream 1 si les
allemands sont d'accord est ce que oui
ou non ça empêche poutine de continuer à
financer sa guerre on à 700 millions de
dollars qui lui arrivent chaque jour
pour ce gaz donc
ça qu on paye ça que l'europe paie en
exportation rousse c'est 4 fois son
budget militaire annuelle pour faire
donc effectivement l asphyxie ray si on
arrêtait si on arrête t il il aurait
beaucoup de mal à se situer parce que
trouver un autre client parce que il y à
une partie donc et là il faut se méfier
des gazoducs c'est des tunnels dassier
qui on peut pas on sait ça et donc il y
as pour le pétrole pour les gaz liquéfié
ça serait beaucoup plus simple mais et
pour la plupart des infrastructures sont
vers l'europe donc ça serait compliqué
pour lui question simple on sait que les
allemands sont beaucoup plus dépendant
que les français c'est un peu plus tôt
60% pour les allemands c'est ça 55 55
nous c'est 20 pourquoi la france ne le
fait pas seul pour montrer l'exemple
quitte à ce qu'on sorte progressivement
est ce que la france pourrait trouver
ailleurs puisqu'on a le nucléaire
notamment en fait ça c'est l'une des
choses qui sont en train d'être discuté
à bruxelles parce que elle la clé c'est
que en france on ne peut pas faire tout
seul parce que on a un marché européen
de l'énergie un marché européen
d'électricité et donc on peut aller vers
des mesures comme celle là mais il faut
qu'on soit tous d'accord et à ces
moments-là décidé comme on l'a fait avec
d autres sujets parce que tant que ça il
faut expliquer c'est pas simple tant que
le prix de l'électricité est indexé sur
celui du gaz ça c'est une règle
européenne alors même nous en france qui
avons d'autres énergies que le gaz et le
pétrole on est défavorisée c'est ça donc
une des choses qui étaient discutés et
et en amont de cette réunion
maintenant c'était justement de
découpler trouver réguler les marchés de
sorte d découpler le marché l'air et
d'électricité du marché du gaz c'est à
dire et couper ses liens de prix là les
allemands ne veulent pas et non et est
aussi une autre une chose c'est le
découplage est donc les femmes est réel
dessalement beaucoup de difficultés et
l'autre c'est ça qui laisse allemands ne
veulent vraiment pas c'est de mettre un
limite donc un pli plafond sur la faune
mans des prix du gaz de les préciser la
deuxième option qui est en discussion
patrick martin genieys sur sur la
question énergétique
il ya aussi une question morale on voit
bien que ça lui couperait les jambes si
j'ose dire
vous nous trouvez à la hauteur ou est ce
que vraiment c'est absolument
inenvisageable pour nos économies
dalé d'aller jusqu'à jusqu'à cet embargo
coté sur le plan politique il ya des
questions morales mais sur le plan
économique c'est inenvisageable parce
que on parle d'autres pays elle en dit
non dépend à hauteur de 20% les
allemands 55% je vous rappellerai que
l'allemagne a fait des choix politiques
aux coups avec angela merkel pendant 15
ans à savoir fermer les centrales
nucléaires et tenter de trouver des
énergies propres le ministre de
l'économie et de la transition
écologique allemand a dit très
clairement qu'il n'y avait pas de
solution alternative si vous couper
totalement les choses énergie cela
pourrait revenir à doubler ou tripler la
facture énergétique pour les ménages est
ce que c'est ça que l'on veut
aujourd'hui notamment pour les ménages
défavorisés
lorsque vous êtes au gouvernement et
notamment c'est un gouvernement social
démocrate il refusera mais même sur
bagneux conservateur enfin très
conservateur ted en élections
législatives en ce moment a dit que 90%
des ménages s'alimentait en gaz russe et
que si on coupait totalement ce gars
cette source d'énergie cela reviendrait
à tripler la facture pour les ménages
dont on voit bien ici que il n'y a aucun
consensus en loin autant on est prêt
c'est très important l'europe et joue un
rôle important pour asphyxier tenter
d'asphyxier l'économie russe autant il
n'y aura pas d'accord pour se priver
totalement du gaz russe d'accord avec ça
le bleu là dessus rapidement puis on va
parler d'entreprises françaises grèce en
russie oui quelque chose de très
important me semble-t-il c'est qu'au
mois de décembre au moment de
l'ultimatum prononcé par vladimir
poutine sur l'ukraine c'est le mois de
décembre c'est le moment où nord stream
2 est terminée d'un point de vue
technique ensuite il ya eu la phase
d'homologation avant de pouvoir ouvrir
d'un stream 2 et il estimé clairement
que du kremlin que dès lors que nothing
day était terminé et devait
approvisionner l'allemagne par 50
millions de mètres cubes de gaz par an
c'est à dire à peu près la moitié de son
utilisation propre et réalités ce qui se
serait passé c'est que l'allemagne
serait devenu le hub européen de
réception du gaz russe donc ce qui se
joue quand même c'est que la décision
allemande de fermer dans scream 2 c'est
une décision d'une ampleur absolument
colossal et je pense que du point de vue
du kremlin il ne s'attendait pas à cette
date dès lors que techniquement dancing
2 était terminée au mois de décembre et
nord stream un a à peu près les mêmes
capacités c'est de l'ordre de 50
millions de mètres cubes de gaz par an
et fonctionne à plein régime donc on a
vraiment un enjeu tout à fait
considérable surtout que l'allemagne est
une de puissance industrielle que ces
usines ont besoin d'énergie et que la
sortie du nucléaire évidemment à
obliger l'allemagne a davantage être
dépendante du gaz et d'ailleurs ils
reviennent sur des décisions
fondamentales telles que le prolongement
l'idée du prolongement des trois
centrales nucléaires actuellement en
fonction en allemagne l'idée du
prolongement de la durée des centrales
au charbon et ses décisions sont prises
par un gouvernement qui comprend des
écologistes en son sein il faut voir que
la révolution est de nature
copernicienne alors question en dernière
question puis ensuite on va parler des
entreprises françaises
il n'y a pas de substitution même si
c'est pas très écolo oui de gaz de
schiste américain il y à il y as
destitution il y a d'ailleurs des
scénarios qui ont été faits récemment
qui montre que si on fait c'est un
embargo donc on commençait de maintenant
on ne serait vraiment en difficulté mais
en beaucoup de difficultés à partir de
septembre
et est donc et
la question elle est importante mais il
y a quelque chose que chevauchent voulu
rebondir là et si on ne régule donc si
on décide de trouver une solution une
solution alternative aux halles et
margot qui ont 17 c'est très compliqué
c'est effectivement réguler le prix du
gaz
on aura de problèmes de consensus mais
il me semble que confirmer sur que va
avancer dans le conflit on va devoir
arriver à une solution et une régulation
du marché parce que les prix peuvent pas
on peut pas continuer avec le rémunérant
à ces prix justement cette emprise
qui sait fournissent de gaz russe mais
voilà on comprend que ça va pas se faire
du jour où l'on n'en a pas terminé avec
les entreprises françaises j'ai pas le
temps de vous montrer le sujet parce que
je voulais c'est un petit peu de temps
un dernier tour de table vous avez
entendu évidemment volodymyr zelensky
hier qui demande le retrait de toute
présence d'entreprises françaises en
russie il a même cité trois d'entre
elles au chant silencieuse depuis hier
leroy merlin qui a annoncé maintenir sa
présence en russie et renault qui a
annoncé son départ quant au président de
la république nicole bacharan eh bien il
a décidé de laisser des entreprises
françaises choisir même s'il a parlé des
faits réputationnel ça vous choque vous
que ces entreprises puissent continuer à
je pense qu'elles vont perdre sur les
deux tableaux
aurait-elle décidé
d'arrêter leur activité en russie ça
aurait été compliqué sur le plan des
emplois et des ressources financières
mais effectivement il y avait un
avantage de réputation évident là elles
vont rester en russie il est le premier
investisseur
jour ou l'autre elles devront quand même
quitté la russie et elle aurait terni
leur réputation parce que plus
qu'amoindri dans tous les autres pays
européens donc c c'est une décision
difficile à prendre de quitter la russie
mais c'est une décision à laquelle nous
pourrons finalement pas échappé mais la
prenons trop tard ils n'auront qu'un
bénéfice après patrick martin jahn et
c'est devenu un enjeu politique
la présence la présence française en
russie les entreprises il ya 160 mille
emplois sur place oui à ennahdha
centaines de milliers effectivement de
salariés je dirais que c'est une
décision purement économique
capitalistique bien sûr on a chacun sa
déontologie le président la république a
bien compris que nous sommes dans une
économie de marché et donc on ne peut
pas forcer les entreprises à partir je
dirais simplement que certains des
remords par exemple renault avait
annoncé il ya deux jours qu'il reprenait
sa chaîne de production et suite à
l'intervention du président volodymyr
zylinski a dit qu'elle arrêtait il ya
d'autres entreprises qui ferment leurs
magasins mais qui ne supprime pas leur
chaîne de production donc finalement
c'est chacun selon ses intérêts lvmh ses
parts et le première lvmh est parti le
premier effectivement oui je crois que
la décision politique avec un grand p à
prendre
des entreprises sont là pour défendre
leurs emplois et c'est au conseil
d'administration à l'entreprise dans une
système d'économie de marché de décider
vous aurez le mot de la fin ronaldo on a
entendu yannick jadot ce matin persisté
et signé contre total estimant que total
énergie très présent en russie étaient
complices d'un crime de guerre lui parle
de crimes de guerre c'est devenu une
question à la fois politique économique
mais assurait ce qu'on pensait qu'elle
va peser dans ce débat présidentiel à 17
jours du premier tour il faut mesurer
l'impact en france parce que prendre des
positions uniquement de principe sans en
mesurer l'impact n'a pas de sens quel
est l'impact pour la vie des français un
élément sur le sur l'énergie est ce que
vraiment on va être capable l'hiver
prochain de couper tout simplement une
partie de l'approvisionnement de dire
aux français de se chauffer moins
d'avoir une multiplication de la facture
énergétique ce qui est en train de se
jouer est absolument phénoménale
l'impact va être immense je pense que
s'ils ont des tri nations et les
sacrifices pour vous n'est as combien
est-ce que les français sont prêts et
dans quelle mesure sont ils prêts
aujourd'hui la cette prise de conscience
n'est pas encore dans l'esprit des gens
et donc il faut mesurer cela il sait le
sait le la responsabilité notamment d'un
chef d'état de prendre la mesure de ce
que la population peut endurer voir ça
dans le temps puisque nous le craignons
tous ce conflit va durer merci beaucoup
merci infiniment est revenue sur le
plateau des cp on va d'ailleurs
continuer à parler des conséquences de
cette guerre en ukraine conséquences sur
nos agriculteurs avec l'envolée des prix
des céréales conséquences aussi pour les
consommateurs dans les supermarchés
puissant d'autres conséquences plus
graves encore pour des millions de
personnes dans des pays en afrique ou au
maghreb emmanuel macron a proposé
aujourd'hui à bruxelles un mécanisme de
solidarité pour éviter des famines dans
les prochains mois comment va-t-il être
mises en oeuvre on a plein plein de
questions à poser à julien de normandie
le ministre de l'agriculture qui nous
rejoint dans un instant juste après ce
sujet des âmes en magasin si on vous
invite julien de normandie c'est parce
que vous avez du pain sur la planche
la guerre entre l'ukraine et la russie
dose énorme exportateur de céréales et
d'engrais fait trembler le marché
agricole et alimentaire mondial si bien
que la sécurité alimentaire est devenue
un enjeu des sommets de l'otan et du g7
il est absolument impérieux que au delà
du cessez-le-feu la russie se montrent
responsables et ne prennent pas en plus
justement cette responsabilité de créer
cette famine qui sinon est à coup sûr
inéluctable julien de normandie vous
avez été ingénieur agronome vous êtes
aujourd'hui ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation dans vos dossiers donc
la crise du blé et ses répercussions
hausse du coût des matières premières
pour les agriculteurs et la menace d'une
flambée des prix dans les supermarchés
il faut être lucide nous sommes dans un
contexte où il ya une forte inflation et
donc oui les prix de l'alimentation dans
les prochaines semaines des prochains
mois vont continuer à augmenter alors si
hier on se demander comment produire
mieux on se demande à présent comment
produire plus la guerre en ukraine a des
conséquences à différentes échelles dans
certains pays le pire est à craindre
selon l'onu alors que la guerre fait
rage en ukraine une épée de damoclès est
suspendue au dessus de l'économie
mondiale en particulier au dessus des
pays en voie de développement nous
devons tout faire pour éviter un ouragan
de famine
en france ce sont les agriculteurs qui
voient leurs coûts explosent et le
gazole les engrais les matières
premières une enveloppe a été débloquée
mais suffira-t-elle et quel impact sur
le pouvoir d'achat après le litre
d'essence le paquet de pâtes à 2 euros
pour vous je viens de normandie la
solution c'est que la france produisent
davantage notamment sur les terres en
jachère même si celles ci sont
indispensables à la biodiversité
alors ce soir nous vous demanderons
comment éviter une crise alimentaire
mondiale faut-il mettre sur pause le
green deal européen
peut-on produire plus et en même temps
produire mieux vous ensemble est
convaincu julien de normandie à vous de
nous le prouver
bonsoir je viens de normandie bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va commencer par le plus
inquiétant le risque de famine qui
pèsent sur certains pays d'afrique et du
maghreb egypte tunisie ou encore soudan
qui sont dépendants on le sait des
livraisons de blé russe et ukrainien à
l'arrêt depuis la guerre expliquez-nous
précisément ce qu'a proposé le chef de
l'état à bruxelles un mécanisme de
solidarité internationale pour éviter le
pire comment va-t-il se mettre en oeuvre
s'il est accepté par par l'ensemble des
partenaires d'abord de quoi parle-t-on
aujourd'hui il faut avoir en tête que
l'ukraine et la russie c'est à peu près
30% des exportations de blé mondiale
l'ukraine et la russie c'est deux fois
plus d'exportations de blé que toute
l'europe et vous avez un certain nombre
de pays pas la france la france est
totalement indépendant souverain dans sa
production de céréales est insuffisante
pas de raison aucun risque de pénurie
mais vous avez un certain nombre de pays
notamment au maghreb par exemple
l'egypte mais d'autres notamment en
afrique qui sont incroyablement
dépendant des importations ukrainiennes
et russes vous prenez ce pays qui
l'egypte c'est plus de 80% de la
consommation en blé qui vient d'ukraine
ou qui vient de russie or ces pays
fondamentalement ont besoin de ces
céréales ont besoin du blé par exemple
l'egypte pays que je connais bien j'y ai
vécu plusieurs années en arabe égyptien
le pain c'est le même mot que la vie
c'est un élément fondamental
l'alimentation et donc on se retrouve
face à des à des importations qui sont
questionnés et au même moment vous avez
une sécheresse qui sévit notamment au
maroc et dans d'autres pays du maghreb
et qui vient en plus obérer les
capacités de production de ces pays là
et donc ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on pousse
au niveau international c'est que à
cette tragédie de la guerre en ukraine
pèse un risque très fort
crise alimentaire à court terme mais
surtout à 12 et 18 mois et une crise
alimentaire souvenez-vous le printemps
arabe le printemps arabe né en tunisie
de la crise du pain et donc on voit bien
toutes les conséquences et cela dénote
alimentaire et comme le dit le
secrétaire général de l'onu de cet
ouvrage alors ça veut dire concrètement
que le président demande aujourd'hui à
bruxelles que les pays producteurs de
blé qui ont des stocks les partage c'est
ça qui te ment sont visés et combien de
stock de surplus sont disponibles de
gérance l'objectif porté par président
de la république à l'initiative de la
france c'est de faire sur le grain sur
le blé ce que nous avions fait il ya
quelques mois sur les vaccins sur les
vaccins nous avions à l'initiative de la
france lancée à l'échelle européenne une
grande initiative qui s'appelle acta qui
visait à offrir au continent africain
des vaccins qu'il n'avait pas la
capacité de se produire ou de se fournir
est donc l'objectif c'est de faire la
même chose mais sur le grain sur le blé
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire d'abord de créer cette initiative
coordonnée internationale pour que les
pays du g7 et les pays européens mettent
en place cette initiative c'est ce que
le président de la république a fait cet
après midi au niveau du g7 et fera ce
soir et demain au niveau européen
puisqu'il préside le conseil européen
moment où 500 millions de stocks de
céréales stockées dans le monde vous
confirmer c'est yannick jadot qui dit
zone est ce chiffre ce matin au concret
si on a le plus qui devra partager
concrètement ça veut dire quoi cette
initiative ça veut dire qu'effectivement
d'abord faut faire de la transparence et
notamment de la transparence sur les
stocks alors on sait qu'un certain
nombre de pays comme la chine sont des
pays qui disposent de stocks la question
de la quantité de stocks de blé en chine
est une question qui n'est pas
transparente c'est très difficile
d'avoir l'information précise essayer ce
qui est vrai pour la chine il est vrai
pour d'autres pays c'est quoi la
conséquence de sa classe innée à
d'énormes stocks exactement et c'est
quoi la conséquence de cela si vous
n'êtes pas de transparence sur la
quantité dont on dispose et la quantité
qu'on est capable de produire alors vous
avez lé marché qui réagit les prix qui
flambent et un certain nombre de pays
qui n'ont quand ils trouvent des
cargaisons qui n'ont pas la capacité des
pays parce que les portiques la
transparence aura des effets sur les
cours objectivement c'est certain donc
le premier élément de cette initiative
c'est de se mettre d'accord au niveau du
g7 qui rassemble beaucoup de ces pays là
au niveau de l'europe pour d'un point de
vue commercial faire la transparence
notre apparence notament de ces pays là
ça veut dire un cap à la chine dans les
pays que vous mentionnez g7 l'union
européenne à partir du moment où vous
créer cette initiative notamment régler
chinois pour galement avec avec la chine
à l'évidence oui ça c'est premiers
éléments en tout cas il faut se battre
pour le faire il faut se battre aussi
pour éviter toute entorse commercial
c'est-à-dire un certain nombre de pays
producteurs qui disent attention moi je
garde mes productions que pour moi et je
n'exporte plus dans ce cas là vous
empêcher un certain nombre de pays
d'avoir accès à ces céréales donc ça
c'est le premier objectif
commercial transparence de l'initiative
qui s'appelle l'initiative farne lancé
par président de la république au niveau
international le deuxième objectif c'est
de faire en sorte que les pays qui
produisent fasse acte de solidarité ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire d'une part
quand on a la capacité de produire plus
comme en europe on le fait et une fois
qu'on a produit plus à ce moment là on
met en place un mécanisme de solidarité
pour pouvoir s'assurer qu'à des prix
convenables un certain nombre de pays
qui n'ont pas accès ou pas suffisamment
accès au blé à l'orge ou à d'autres
céréales puis ces derniers y avoir accès
par exemple en europe je me suis
beaucoup battu ces derniers jours et la
commission européenne n'a suivi
l'annoncé hier en europe on va utiliser
des terres non destructive et qui
s'appelle les jachères pour pouvoir
produire plus ça me progressant frange
eu le temps d'avoir volé sa corde
troisième volet j'en termine de cette
initiative farm c'est d'investir aux
côtés de nos partenaires pour que nos
partenaires puissent eux aussi augmenter
leurs capacités de production dans les
céréales ou dans les protéines aviaires
en afrique par exemple on a lancé une
initiative très importante qui s'appelle
la grande muraille verte avec les pays
d'afrique subsaharienne où là on
investit à leurs côtés pour lutter
contre la désertification et investir
dans la culture de protéines nécessaires
pour l'alimentation humaine ou animale
et voilà ces cétacés
commercial solidarité de production et
de d'envoi de grains et
investissements dans les outils de
production chez nos partenaires qui
constituent cette initiative femme doris
que vous l'avez dit famine 12 à 18 mois
vous pensez que ce mécanisme peut se
mettre en oeuvre il va falloir
convaincre bien sûr mais mais quand il
ya urgence évidemment exactement et puis
c'est à l'initiative de l'initiative de
la france de ceux de faire en sorte que
tous les pays se retrousse les manches
prennent conscience de la gravité de la
situation et vous remarquerez moi ça
fait des semaines président de la
république aussi que nous alertons là
dessus quand je prends l'europe sur la
question d'utiliser ces jachères pour
produire plus ça paraissait impensable
alors sa chérie j'ai émis l'idée va
s'arrêter là le 1er mars la commission
l'a validé le 23 mars voilà ont cédé
hier donc la commission va s'arrêter là
dessus a acté hier la remise en culture
des terres en jachère ça veut dire que
les 4% que les agriculteurs ne pouvait
pas cultiver jusqu'à présent pour
respecter notamment la biodiversité ils
vont pouvoir le faire mais la question
qui se pose forcément ça veut dire ccssl
de du mieux produire c'est à dire
produire plus tout en respectant
l'écologie ça n'est pas possible
manifestement c'était la commission
elle-même qui est un nom il ajoute je
m'inscris en faux c'est totalement
possible c'est d'ailleurs ce à la voie
de progrès c'est d'ailleurs ce hack sur
lequel moi je me bats la tête de ce
ministère depuis plus de deux ans c'est
de sortir ceux de ce débat complètement
futile qui serait soit on produit soit
en protège aujourd'hui ça s'appelle le
progrès il est possible de produire plus
en protégeant ses crédits
l'environnement de normandie la
commission européenne qui devait
présenter deux textes fondamentaux sur
le green deal ferme tout forte deux
textes de lois a reporté cette
présentation voilà pourquoi la reporter
ce que la guerre en ukraine à cergy donc
elle prend en compte que ça veut dire
qu'on remet à plus tard c'est
objectivement non non non elle remet en
compte elle prend en compte par dont le
fait que jusqu'à présent la vision
politique de l'agriculture européens
c'était une vision fondée uniquement sur
les transitions et aujourd'hui au niveau
européen au niveau mondial on se rend
compte que ces transitions sont
impérieuse mais il faut aussi qu'on peut
fixer
concrètement je vous donne un exemple
très concret ces fameuses jachère moi ce
que je pousse ce que j'ai proposé ces
dix mètres des protéines des protéines
végétales des légumineuses je rende pas
dans le détail c'est quoi ces plantes
ces plantes il s'avère que ce sont des
plantes incroyablement bénéfique pour
l'environnement pourquoi parce que c'est
des plantes qui capte la zot qui ce
faisant lutte contre le changement
climatique les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et qui plus est quand vous
introduisez ces plantes dans vos
rotations culturales ça veut dire que
vous avez pour la culture suivante
beaucoup moins d'engrais à m et il
s'avère que c'est en grèce sont des
souvent des substances qui émettent des
gaz à effet de serre et donc vous voyez
qu'on peut créer des cercles bien doté
par exemple vous produisez plus de
protéines dont on a besoin c'est mieux
pour l'environnement c'est mieux pour la
lutte contre le changement climatique et
ses des plantes incroyable à la
important je voudrais qu'on parle aussi
des agriculteurs il faut sortir de ce
volet binaire c'est soit produire plus
soit protégé plus il est possible de
faire les deux ça s'appelle juste le
progrès c'est miser sur la science sur
la raison sur les nouvelles technologies
sur ces pratiques mais ne reste peu de
temps pour aborder la question de nos
agriculteurs et des consommateurs que
nous sommes aussi évidemment l'explosion
des prix des matières premières des
ongrais de l'alimentation animale des
carburants font qu'ils sont très
lourdement pénalisé il ya 400 millions
d'euros c'est le plan de résilience qui
leur ont été débloqués pour limiter la
hausse des coûts de production
est-ce que ça va suffire en tout cas on
fait tout pour venir accompagner nos
agriculteurs effectivement sur
l'alimentation animale dont les prix
explosent en ce moment on a une
enveloppe de 400 millions d'euros avec
une aide qu'on est en train de finaliser
pour qu'elle soit la plus rapide
possible mais on apporte en plus des
aides sur les prix des carburants des
aides sur les primes des gaz des aides
sur les exonérations fiscales et
sociales pour nos agriculteurs le plus
en difficulté et comment faire
c'est près d'un supermarché ed arrive le
plus vite possible alors après si on va
dépasser les 4% notre objectif c'est
quoi c'est de limiter les coûts de
production et quand vous limiter les
coûts de production dé facto vous
limiter l'inflation après il faut être
lucide dans le contexte de guerre sur le
sol européen il y à une inflation ont le
on la vit tous les jours et cette
inflation concrètement elle veut dire
quoi elle veut dire que les industriels
la grande distribution doivent prendre
leur part de responsables je sais que
vous les avez vu ce matin on met une
grande pression devant tubes comme on
dit pour faire en sorte que ça ne soit
pas seule les agriculteurs qui assume
cela parce que ce serait quoi la
conséquence demain vous aurez des
agriculteurs qui peuvent plus se
rémunérer donc après demain vous
n'auriez plus d'agriculture et donc
après après demain vous n'auriez plus
votre indépendance alimentaire est ce
que dans la période c'est ça qu'on
souhaite à l'évidence non heureusement
qu'on est indépendant en termes
d'alimentation donc il faut absolument
que les industriels et la grande
distribution prennent leur part de
responsabilité nous notre rôle au sein
du gouvernement ses limites et des coûts
de production pour après limiter
l'inflation mais ensuite chacun doit
assumer sa responsabilité et je dis ça
en ayant conscience des conséquences
mais il faut toujours se dire c'est quoi
l'option alternative l'option
alternative c'est de faire en sorte que
les agriculteurs n'arrivent plus à vivre
n'arrive plus à se rémunérer et donc on
perd notre indépendance alimentaire à
l'évidence ce serait dramatique donc oui
on réunit toutes les semaines je dis
bien toutes les semaines ces industriels
cette grande distribution pour faire en
sorte qu'elles jouent le jeu pour
l'avenir dira si cette période très
tendue pour le monde agricole vous
donnera raison merci beaucoup merci
merci je viens de normandie d'être passé
sur le plateau dacp ce soir on passe au
scan 17 jours avant le premier tour et
chaque soir vous le savez en fait
campagne qu'on passe au crible tous
ensemble regarder
mais avant mais il y a les deux bras de
fatalité au grand remplacement et de la
mole vous propose le rose dalmore d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
aux exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur la russie à cela pas de mystère
c'est de vol
3 scanner à dix sept jours exactement du
premier tour nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau thomas legrand bonsoir merci
france inter et chroniqueurs on ne sait
qu'ils ont changé de nom c'étaient les
affranchis cw scanner pour scanner de
presse voulant pas que vous allez nous
parler du choix des mots notamment vive
la république vive la france deux
candidats ont fait leur choix et vous
nous direz pourquoi bonsoir stephan laï
de blako de 20 ans benjamin orange
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez passé au
crible des réseaux sociaux la question
des entreprises françaises qui décide de
rester en russie ou pas on verra stade
en un instant l'oig votre oeil par quoi
est il a été attiré aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mes deux j'avais dit
aujourd'hui que pour doudou parce que
évidemment emmanuel macron est en tête
de tous les sondages est ce que vous
savez pourquoi non me dis pas la gare en
ukraine ne me dites pas les piles qui me
convient ni même son bilan il est en
tête parce qu' edouard philippe ne s'est
pas présentée tout simplement et
regardez moi si on avait demandé aux
français de choisir il aurait largement
préféré voter pour edouard philippe
plutôt qu emmanuel macron bien voilà
aujourd'hui l'homme près aux politiques
préférées des français peu de son retour
il était en meeting à nice pour soutenir
ma qu'on peut dire que emmanuel macway
et apprécier ce sondage comment s'est
passé ce meeting mais s'imaginer la la
la joie des marcheurs des
alpes-maritimes venus en masse pour ba
soutenir le héros l'ancien premier
ministre fêter avec lui c'est cette
victoire qui leur tend les bras mais
alors le problème c'est que doudou a
plombé l'ambiance d'emblée la douche
froide on les écoute si vous vous
retrancher vers les sondages pour vous
rassurer vous vous retrancher derrière
rien derrière du vide derrière une image
qui ne correspond pas forcément à ce qui
sera demain et dont il est permis de
penser qu'elle ne correspond pas
forcément à ce qui est déjà aujourd'hui
voilà notre se sont fait engueuler par
bach barre philippe alors qu'est ce qui
pourrait empêcher emmanuel macron gagner
ben vous répéter ce qu'il a dit là il
vient de le dire il a dit ce qui
pourrait l'empêcher de gagner c'est de
croire aux sondages mais oui parce que
là depuis la guerre maquereau ou des sur
son nuage à 30% il a même plus envie de
faire campagne à vrai dire en sa
conférence de presse quatre heures au
quai il nous a montré qu'il était hyper
brillant quand je savais déjà ce qui
compte c'est savoir ce qu'on a retenu
qu'est ce qu'on a retenu ben moi j'ai du
mal à vous dire ce que je veux dire
c'est un peu comme les retraites et les
conditions d'utilisation des trucs apple
si vous voulez c'est à dire que
on commence à les lire on se dit que
c'est important y en a 16 pages
finalement on signifie qu'on se dit bon
c'est apple quand même ça va aller et là
c'est pas ils sont pas son maquereau à
son programme top a expliqué en disant
oui bien sûr bon c'est macron ça va
aller après tout c'est vrai qu'on n'a
rien retenu le rsa avec contreparties
non très bon exemple cette histoire du
rsa quand il a annoncé l'idée qui
auraient travaillé 15 heures pour les
récents ne comprenait pas dit on va
faire travailler ça va des tâches
d'intérêt général ça va être de la
formation dont qui la durée expliqué
tout saillard sur m6 mais comme il est
trop long comme moi d'ailleurs il est
bien il n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout
moi j'irai jusqu'au bout si on veut
réussir cette bataille du plein emploi
il faut pas simplement verser le rsa il
faut accompagner demandé et c'est le
contrat de confiance un engagement c'est
ces quasars batteur d'activités
d'insertion de formation
si on trouve ce faisant aujourd'hui les
médias le candidat on vous a entendu
notre merci vous me permettez je le lis
je sais que tu arrivais plus là on va
passer à la jeunesse maintenant mais je
la glisse quand même une grande loi sur
des horloges ici qu'ailleurs quick ben
oui ce n'est que le candidat macron pas
bon je vous rassure il a quand même pu
s'exprimer cinq minutes avant et puis
surtout il ya 80% des français qu'ils
sont d'accord avec çà propositions sur
le rsa donc c'est certainement pas là
dessus qui va perdre l'élection est donc
je vous répète ma question qu'est ce qui
pourrait l'empêcher de gagner plus de la
cité nous est pire que xavier de moulins
et mais insistait je vais vous dire si
vous aussi vous allez je vous le dis ben
c'est la ferme à qinze est évidemment
pour l'instant c'est quoi un petit gravi
dans la chaussure mais est-ce que ça va
pas devenir une épine dans son pied
parce que hier soir le candidat mac on
nous a dit qu'il était choqué commence à
mckinley ne payez pas d'impôts en france
depuis dix ans mais c'est pas possible
un scandale pareil alors votez macron et
c'est promis demain ça n'arrivera plus
on écoute qui nous choque tous c'est que
des cabinets comme ça où des grandes
multinationales ne paient pas parce
qu'elles peuvent échapper sa ont donc
demain ce ne sera plus possible je
pourrais pas corrigé le passé parce que
je peux pas changer de droit fiscal en
particulier international d'hier mais
parce que j'ai travaillé ces cinq
dernières années je peux vous dire qu'à
celui de demain va changer c'est
ça n'a pas l'air de vous interroger
pourtant moi ça m'intéresse je me
demandais comment se fait-il que ce qui
maintenant que les candidats ne le
choque ce scandale maquilleuse est quand
il est impressionnant ne le choquait pas
du tout au point qui leur a demandé pour
1 milliard de conseil c'est des
questions mon avis laquelle il va devoir
répondre il reste quand même presque
trois semaines oui on verra ça d'un
candidat à deux autres vous nous parler
ce soir de jean luc mélenchon et d'eric
zemmour thomas qui ont réveillé des
traditions antagonistes bien française
oui et c'est le candidat polémiste en
réalité qui réanime le premier la
vieille cordes de la droite
maurrassienne et il le fait par un
vocable bien typés un très codé codé
historiquement que tout le monde
comprend il commence et finit tous ces
discours de meeting depuis qu'il est
entré en campagne par ce petit cette
petite interjections
vive la république et surtout
la vive la république et surtout vive la
france à l'ordre mais surtout l'arrêt tu
es donc surtout bien sûr mettre la
france au dessus de la république s'est
refusée le consensus établi depuis par
le conseil national de la résistance
selon lequel l'identité politique de la
france bien c'est la république on peut
pas les dissocier et on peut pas les
hiérarchiser si l'on remet en cause par
exemple par cette phrase d'apparence
sibylline le caractère essentiel à la
france de la république et bien on remet
en cause le principe selon lequel être
français n'a rien à voir avec le sens
l'origine l'ethnie et donc eric zemmour
tente de 2,2 par des petites phrases
comme ça vers les petites touches de 2,2
de faire cesser de donner ces signes qui
ne sont pas républicains qui sont contre
l'esprit de la république alors que jean
luc mélenchon lui a décidé au lieu du
traditionnel vive la république et vive
la france de dire
vive la france et surtout
voilà il a inversé le propos effet
miroir fait exprès vive la france et
surtout vive la république le défenseur
de la nation version valmy de la
république et ses idéaux désormais
indissociable de la france et mouret
mélenchon en fait sont deux
manifestations deux autres
manifestations delà de la disparition du
clivage gauche droite alors que chacun à
leur façon marine le pen par une sorte
de populisme à la fois autoritaire et et
sociales et emmanuel macron par un sort
d'une sorte de pragmatisme trans
partisan temps d'effacer le clivage
gauche droite est bien ses mots et
mélenchon reviennent à avant le clivage
gauche-droite 1 du temps où s'opposer
une sorte de la france éternelle
le légitimisme dirait rené rémond versus
la république des lumières
c'est
donc la république benjamin il restait
les deux minutes pour nous parler aux
forces de la grande polémique de ces
deux derniers jours les entreprises
françaises qui choisissent de rester en
russie doivent être doivent-elles être
boycottés question peut-être qui fait
réagir les internautes vous avez regardé
de près les réseaux sociaux oui on dit
que l'opinion agit tel un cours de
bourse eh bien là c'est vrai et c'est
vrai que c'est les entreprises
françaises qui sont dans la cible pour
celles qui continuent à opérer en russie
et toutes ces entreprises elles se sont
exprimées sur le sujet depuis évidemment
sous le poids et la pression de
l'opinion publique et quelle pression
alors l'appel au boycott il est majeur à
l'instar en fait de ce tweet qui établit
clairement la présence en russie et le
financement de la guerre alors
quantitativement le sujet du boycott il
est il est majeur et revient intensément
ces derniers jours c'est presque vingt
mille mention le 22 mars c'est à dire
presque autant que pendant le pic des
conversations sur les sanctions alors
dans le top 25 on va retrouver plutôt le
top du cac 40 on a renault on a total
avec ce hashtag la honte totale auchan
leroy-merlin roland leroy merlin est
encore décathlon est alors quand on
regarde les méthodes qui sont employés
se sont à peu près toujours les mêmes
soit on incite à la péta ciel à pic ici
en ligne et là on a le cas avec contre
leroy merlin soit finalement on détourne
une image de guerre on y insérant la
marque est ici avec renault pour essayer
de faire réagir et finalement de toucher
les sentiments des des consommateurs
troisième approche qui a été utilisé par
les internautes c'est finalement
d'inonder presque de retweet chaque
communication d'une marque comme avec le
groupe auchan finalement le mode
d'emploi est simple on propose un copier
coller et chaque fois qu au chant
finalement fait une communication bien
chaque internaute en copié-collé va
remettre le lien vers l'appel au boycott
à carpète bonne et ça marche et ça
marche très bien alors qui programme ces
machines mais c'est à dire que à qui
profite le crime en fait à qui profite
le crime alors c'est vrai que danser
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
une partie finalement de 7 de cette
approche de cette dynamique et naturel
qui est spontanée avec des vraies
personnes sincères qui poste et qui sont
animés d'une dynamique ainsi oculaire
mais il ya aussi comme voulu différé
hier les machines et on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui à qui profite le crime
encore ce qui est sûr c'est que la
conséquence c'est la même c'est que
l'opinion publique force ces entreprises
récalcitrantes à rejoindre l'union
sacrée du boycott même si aujourd'hui
elle tend à s'effriter merci beaucoup
pas sûr que dans la durée rester en
russie ce soit très payant merci merci à
vous trois très belles soirées
documentaires qui commence maintenant
l'accueil jean pierre gratien à demain
[Musique]